[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans le sais tu ce
week-end sur tv 78 actualité idées de
sorties pour bien terminer la semaine
dans les yvelines voici le programme de
ce 3 juin vous l'avez sans doute
constaté il est très difficile en ce
moment de renouveler son document
d'identité 65 jours en moyenne pour
obtenir son passeport ou sa carte
d'identité sans parler des rendez vous
en mairie avec souvent plusieurs mois
d'attentes le gouvernement a présenté le
mois dernier un plan d'urgence en la
matière j - 9 avant le premier tour des
élections législatives les électeurs ont
rendez vous aux urnes le 12 juin pendant
la campagne tv 60,18 vous présenter les
enjeux dans chacune des aides 12
circonscription des yvelines dernier
zoom dans cette émission sur la 12e
circonscription
et puis comme tous les vendredis nos
idées de sorties pour samedi et dimanche
dans les yvelines la jeunesse en fait à
poissy ou encore une croisière sur la
seine ce sera dans la deuxième partie de
cette émission le sais tu ce week-end
qui vous est proposé pour une dernière
fois cette saison une ultime occasion de
retrouver mon acolyte du vendredi en
plateau c'est bixente mayence artistes
et bane bonjour bixente paris pour cette
dernière ensemble très près et au rejet
après j'ai divulgue h et quelques peu
votre programme du jour et vos idées de
sorties puisque votre mission chaque
vendredi c'est donner l'envié aux
yvelinois de sortir dans leur
département quel programme avez vous
concocter aujourd'hui bien un programme
on ne peut plus complet aujourd'hui
grégory animation jeunesse croisière
salon littéraire expo d'art contemporain
spectacles festivals de musique il ya de
quoi faire on ya de quoi faire et ce
sera bien sûr tout à l'heure dans le
sais tu ce week-end
[Musique]
l'actualité d'abord avec ses longs
délais d'attenté pour obtenir en ce
moment sa carte d'identité ou son
passeport il faut compter environ deux
mois pour avoir ce document délivré
difficile aussi d'obtenir un rendez-vous
en mairie pour valider votre demande une
conséquence des retards pris pendant la
crise sanitaire il ya un mois le
gouvernement a présenté face à cette
problématique son plan d'urgence le
reportage à la préfecture des yvelines à
versailles est aussi à montigny le
bretonneux de patrick jacques de dixmude
et nicolas landry
renouveler sa carte d'identité ou son
passeport un véritable parcours du
combattant c'est le cas notamment à la
mairie de montigny le bretonneux les
possibilités de prise de rendez vous sur
internet sont très rares et les dix
agents des affaires générales sont
mobilisés au quotidien face à cette
hausse très importante des demandes
depuis qu'on a repris après le
confinement de déconfinement la série
est vraiment complet tous les jours on a
énormément de demandes des appels
téléphoniques et des demandes urgentes
avoir bouché une personne pour augmenter
nos capacités d'accueil mais les
problèmes ça se fait pas comme ça
rapidement parce qu'il faut une
formation il faut que ce soit
à griller par la préfecture parce que ça
touche la société nationale d'après les
estimations deux fois plus de cartes
d'identité de passeports seront délivrés
en 2022 par rapport à 2020 c'est aussi
une hausse de 1000 documents délivrés
par rapport à 2010 9
les délais peuvent être allongée pour
les usagers tu peux être un petit peu de
chances que ça s'est fait plutôt assez
vite j'ai pris mon petit rendez vous sur
internet et ça a très bien fonctionné
donc ça a été relativement stable avec
la peine trois semaines si vous venez
retirer mon passeport et voilà j'ai fait
la démarche il ya quand même un certain
temps j'ai eu beaucoup de mal à obtenir
un rendez-vous pour déposer ma demande
de passeport et puis après il ya une pas
d' un délai d'à-peu-près 3 4 semaines
pour que je puisse venir le récupérer un
mois pour obtenir sa pièce d'identité
après le dépôt de la demande en mairie
c'est le délai moyen dans les yvelines
les dossiers sont ensuite traitées par
le centre d'expertisé et de ressources
des titres à la préfecture des yvelines
trente agents instructeur vérifie les
pièces et les informations concernées
par les demandes près de 6500 demande
yvelinois sont reçus en préfecture
chaque semaine en 2020 on a eues sur
l'année de 190000 demande en 2021 3 178
milles et rien que sur les quatre
premiers mois de l'année nous sommes
déjà à 178 1000 demandes reçues les
agents du cert sont volontaires par
exemple pour faire des samedis
travaillés donc en plus de leur temps de
travail pour renforcer les équipes de la
préfecture trois agents contractuels ont
été recrutés au mois de mai 2022
les élections législatives approchent le
premier tour est au programme le 12 juin
prochain tv 78,2 vous aide à y voir plus
clair sur les enjeux dans chacune des 12
circonscription des yvelines dernier
focus aujourd'hui avec michael et demi
d'euros bonjour bonjour de la rédaction
de tv 78 avec vous on va parler
justement de la 12e circonscription déjà
où se situe ce territoire dans les
événements cette circonscription est
situé au centre des yvelines et au monde
vers le nord du département elle englobe
23 communes on retrouve des villes de
tailles importantes comme quoi si on
encore plaisir des communes de taille
moyenne avec bell ou orgeval mais
également des petites communes avec toi
hrivik neauphle-le-château ville mahieu
bois six ans à bord ou encore
goupillière un territoire entre zones
urbaines et ruralité chez les cartes
seront redistribuées dans cette
circonscription puisque la députée
sortante florence granger ne se
représente pas effectivement grigori
florence granger élu sous l'étiquette la
république en marche a décidé de ne pas
se représenter pour un second mandat sur
la 12e circonscription à la selon ses
mots préféré laisser sa place après cinq
ans elle avait remporté ce territoire en
2017 en obtenant 56 63 % des suffrages
face à david douillet du parti
républicain une vraie surprise à
l'époque puisque ce territoire voter
principal à droite et du coup qui sont
les candidats pour ce scrutin alors le
parti de la majorité présidentielle ne
compte pas abandonner cette
circonscription qui lui semble promise
aux élections présidentielles d'avril
dernier quelques exemples emmanuel
macron avait réalisé 31,2 28% à des
suffrages à poissy au premier tour et 75
2% au second orgeval le président
sortant avait réalisé 44 60 % au premier
tour et 76 % au second a plaisir à même
dynamique emmanuel macron est devant au
premier et au second tour pour garder ce
territoire karl olive a été choisi par
la majorité présidentielle maire de
poissy depuis 2014 il est très proche du
président il se présentera sous
l'étiquette ensemble il est également
conseiller départemental des yvelines
depuis 2015 à 53 ans il se présente pour
la première fois à la députation il aura
face à lui un candidat ait l'air
françois moutot il est élu depuis près
de 30 ans à la mairie de thoiry cet
ingénieur agronome de formation n'a pas
hésité à se porter candidat sur cette
12e circonscription il compte sur son
implantation locale pour l'emporter il y
aura aussi un candidat anubis avec edwin
le gris un écologiste qui espère surfer
sur les bons résultats de jean luc
mélenchon et des écologistes dans la
circonscription en avril dernier pour
l'emporter en ce mois de juin le
candidat multiplient à ces derniers
jours les tractages sur le terrain le
rassemblement national sera aussi
présent sur le secteur avec jean-louis
mail met les ce conseiller en formation
était déjà candidat au premier tour des
élections municipales de mars 2020 à
plaisir là le partir aux conquêtes sera
aussi présent dans cette circonscription
avec sabine clément cette femme de 56
ans mère de trois enfants et heavy noise
depuis 20 ans veut transmettre sa
passion française à tout ça va tenter de
percer sur ce territoire qui n'a pas été
très réceptif aux idées d'eric zemmour
lors de la dernière présidentielle il y
aura quatre autres candidats également
egor également jean pierre mercier porte
parole de lutte ouvrière il est ouvrier
cariste chez sts et anti sa poisse il
était déjà candidat en 2017 il avait
réalisé un score de 0,60 % il ya cinq
ans le party animal y sera aussi présent
avec mathieu pea paranthoën un
protecteur du bien-être à nîmes elle
espère faire 4 % sur la circonscription
avec ses propositions il veut notamment
interdire la chasse à courre sommes
enfin il y a quatre autres candidats qui
se présenteront dimitri carbonnel
candidat écologiste indépendant il y
aura aussi à la mine boudrias de l'union
des démocrates musulmans français et
deux autres candidats indépendants jean
marc tran et isabelle fourni hier au
total il y aura onze candidats sur cette
12e si vous anticipez dit qu'il restait
quatre candidats il reste un peu plus et
au total onze candidats sur cette 12e
circonscription des yvelines voici
toutes les informations à retenir et à
connaître sur cette circonscription des
yvelines merci michael pour ce point
d'information et le tour d'horizon des
circonscriptions est maintenant terminée
retrouvez tous les enjeux
circonscription par circonscription et
aussi la liste complète de ces candidats
yvelinois pour les élections
législatives sur notre site internet tv
78 points comme le rappelle lé date de
ce scrutin les 12 et 19 juin prochain
une nouvelle semaine s'achève dans les
yvelines avec quelques faits marquants
ce qu'il faut retenir de l'actualité en
70 secondes 78 secondes s'est résumée
par céline charles
[Musique]
plus de quatre mille collégiens des
yvelines étaient hauts de seine se sont
rendus au château de versailles pour
découvrir le château et son histoire
lampard compte athlon des arts au
programme arts de la scène arts visuels
numériques architecture ou encore
littérature l'académie de versailles
recrute elle a organisé un job dating
destination des demandeurs d'emploi des
personnes en reconversion ou des
étudiants en fin d'études objectif
compléter ses effectifs et préparer la
rentrée prochaine plus de 400 postes
sont à pourvoir dans les yvelines
le maire de ville jean baptiste à
monique et le maire de port marly cédric
panda marines ont lancé un partenariat
visant à récolter des fonds pour
l'association mécénat chirurgie
cardiaque
ils veulent récolter 24000 euros pour
permettre à des enfants cardiaques
d'être opéré en france et accueillis
dans des familles des deux communes
la seconde édition des assises du
numérique organisé par seine et yvelines
numériques le département des yvelines
et les hauts de seine a élu aux
pyramides de port marly tables rondes et
ateliers autour des différents enjeux du
numérique étaient organisées tout au
long de la journée
placée sous la responsabilité du château
de versailles depuis 2019 le domaine
national de marly le roi a été reconnue
jardin remarquable par le ministère de
la culture une labellisation qui
récompense le patrimoine historique
environnementale admirable qu'il
représente
[Musique]
comme chaque vendredi votre rubrique
elle légale checking du jour pour
décrypter l'actualité c'est avec le
collectif des surligneurs raphaël mata
duvignau nous parle aujourd'hui des
suites de la polémique à grenoble autour
du burkina dans les piscines
alain carignon ancien maire de grenoble
a salué la décision du tribunal
administratif qui suspend l'exécution de
la délibération du conseil municipal
modifiant le règlement intérieur des
piscines publiques afin d'autoriser le
port du burkini des juristes et nous les
premiers prévoyait le rejet du déferré
laïcité du préfet de l'isère or le
tribunal admistratif a surpris son monde
en effet le juge a renversé les
perspectives alors que la plupart des
observateurs l'attendaient sur le
terrain burqini et laïcité centré sur le
baigneur
on sait que le burqini n'est pas en soit
contraire à la laïcité selon le conseil
d'état lui même le tribunal a plutôt
choisi d'examiner l'attitude de
l'autorité en charge du service public
sur le thème conseil municipal et
neutralité des services publics le
conseil municipal doit en effet
respecter les grands principes de
service public dont l'égalité et la
neutralité ce qui inclut donc la laïcité
et en examinant le règlement de la
piscine le juge administratif s'est
rendu compte que la modification
apportée était millimétré pour autoriser
le burqini et aucune autre tenue de bain
en effet le règlement continue d'imposer
les tenues moulantes très près du corps
excluant notamment les shorts les jupes
ou les boxers long mais il ajoute une
exception pour les tenues non près du
corps sous la seule condition qu'elles
soient moins longues que la mi-cuisse
clairement c'est le burqini qui est visé
et qui est donc autorisé
en somme son et tribunal le conseil
municipal à rédiger un règlement qui a
en réalité pour seul objectif
d'autoriser un vêtement religieux bien
déterminé le conseil municipal a donc
enfreint le principe de neutralité du
service public en créant sciemment pour
des raisons religieuses une dérogation à
l'obligation de porter des vêtements de
bain près du corps
voilà qui devrait faire donc gamberger
au conseil d'état qui est saisie en
appel soit il annule la décision du
tribunal nistre hâtif et le règlement de
piscine pourra donc entrer en vigueur
soit ils confirment la position du
tribunal et alors tout sera à refaire
pour le maire de grenoble
allez c'est l'heure de sortir dans les
yvelines dans ce set week-end
[Musique]
avec de nouveaux en plateau bixente
mayence anti steban direction poissy
pour débuter on célèbre la jeunesse
jeunesse en fête ce samedi 4 juin de
nombreuses animations sont prévues sur
la place de la république de 14 heures à
19 heures avec des invités de renom
présents pour en parler audrey le père
concert municipale déléguée à la
jeunesse à poissy bonjour bonjour
bixente mon jour e ri je vous remercie
pour l'invitation donc c'est vrai que
cette cette jeunesse en fait n'a pas été
célébrée depuis 2010 9 voudrait qu'on a
eu la crise sanitaire on a eu les
examens et aujourd'hui on n'attend que
ça hier j'ai eu des journées portes
ouvertes à la source qui est le guichet
unique et qui n'attendait effectivement
que tu vois célébrer la jeunesse
après si on est 40 mille habitants et on
et 38 % de jeunes de moins de 22 ans
donc aujourd'hui en fait ce qui est
important c'est pour se retrouver on a
une mixité sans habits de poissy qui est
assez vaste et donc samedi prochain le
le 4 juin sera pleine de la clique donc
en face de la mairie de 14 heures à 19
heures on nous allons célébrer de
nombreuses activités on aurait
effectivement de la danse de la street
dance de la danse afro on va parler du
programme dans un sens mais pourquoi
c'est important pour la ville de poissy
de fêter sa jeunesse c'est très
important parce que ça fait depuis 2000
19 qu'on n'a pas encore fêté et donc la
crise sanitaire qui a été extrêmement
douloureuse pour les pour les jeunes
serment qui crucial ça manque vont se
retrousser un moment effectivement peut
parler de différents sujets un peu pour
fédérer la diversité qu'on a en
positionnant 14 quartiers la ville de
poissy et c'est important de pouvoir un
peu se partager se rencontrer et
notamment de pouvoir un peu bas car la
fête après cette crise sanitaire on a
besoin d'eux de célébrer un petit peu la
jeunesse et je pense qu'il faut en
parler encore plus guest présents
notamment quel est le programme des
animations et des stands animations des
démonstrations des initiations aussi
alors cette année fut très contente
parce qu'on a utilisé toute la place de
la république on va à la fois faire des
activités sportives dont des défis
sportifs comme le pana football comme le
teck ball a également sur un skate park
avec ada touski draisienne trottinette
est également le bmx est également de la
danse la danse afro et beaucoup de
chorégraphies du krump donc des
nouvelles activités que les autres
communes non pas je tiens aussi à le
préciser que ce sont des jeunes pis elle
km également tous types de jeunes qui
viennent de différentes communes donc
c'est vraiment ouvert et c'est gratuit à
tout le monde et pour vous répondre
cette année on a beaucoup de chance
parce que nous avons quatre grandes
l'espace avant quelqu'un qu'on connaît
très bien nous atv 68 devine sky
youtuber football qui a créé son propre
club dans les yvelines levine skype
c'est pourquoi pourquoi lui d'abord tout
est pas parce qu ils représentent la
jeunesse il est extrêmement reconnu sur
les réseaux sociaux il est venu à de
nombreuses fois en fait sur la ville de
poissy notamment pour faire de la
prévention sur les réseaux sociaux et
c'est quelqu'un qui est à la fois à
l'ecoute sur les jeunes qui connaît très
très bien le milieu footballistique et
c'est quelqu'un qui est aussi une écoute
et une très grande visibilité sur les
sur les eaux sociaux et donc j'ai bien
vérifié il ya un bien samedi
donc on avis combine sky pardon naïve
timos fristel qu'ils étaient deux champs
deux fois champion de france de foot
freestyle robin beau risque est le
meilleur street rider en ile de france
manu massabeau va qui a été champion de
france de bmx et femmes de tous les
sports extrêmes c'est ça normal et en a
une aussi mignon femmes aux seins nus
très qui est jose de football
professionnel du psg et un personnel des
équipes de france donc on a quand même
un panel de guest assez sérieuse pour
cette fête et on vient directement pas
d'inscription activités gratuites
complètement ouvert complètement gratuit
et en a envie de pétillement de d'ouvrir
un peu plus les portes des activités
sportives mais notamment si sur des
nouveautés des croisements de danse des
croisements de chant j'ai envie aussi
pouvoir ouvrir ses portes parce qu'il ya
également des activités de jeux de
société il ya également un atelier de
mangas donc j'ai envie d'ouvrir les
portes notamment sur le sport qui a des
nouveautés mais également sur des
activités d un peu nouvelle est donc un
de ceux projetés pour l'année prochaine
aussi donc un peu réveiller un peu les
pépites qui existe et que j'aimerai un
peu plus mettre en lumière
je rappelle vous êtes conseil municipal
à la jeunesse à poissy la jeunesse en
fait donc ce samedi 4 juin à poissy de
nombreuses animations sont prévues sur
la place de la république de 14 heures à
19 heures avec des invités on en parlait
de renan présent les infos sur le site
internet de la ville merci à notre
invité à oudon bixente sur le retour
d'un rendez vous artistique mais
jusqu'au 26 juin la 3e biennale de
l'estampé habite la tanière doux dans un
espace d'art contemporain
au total dix huit artistes décline le
thème morsures et autres empreintes
reportage au premier abord c'est un
grand espace blanc mais sur chaque mur
de la tanière de houdan se trouvent
plusieurs restants je vous présente
catherine gillet c'est du pur burin
c'est à dire qu'elle a employé le même
le même burin que durèrent au xvème
siècle ça c'est le l'outillage k6 le
classique c'est des petits traits on
creuse le cuir et qu'un petit burin ça
c'est la gravure sur bois de raul
vignasse
chaque couleur à une planche et son tir
est successivement
pour pour atteindre ce ses effets
colorés de matière c'est très très
proche de la peinture finalement
beaucoup plus proche de la peinture peu
noir et blanc cette exposition de
gravures intitulé morsures et autres
empreintes en accès libre jusqu'au 26
juin est le fruit du travail de 18
artistes on voulait montrer cette
diversité et cette capacité que les
graveurs on
de rebondir c'est à dire qu'il ne
s'enferme pas dans des techniques fondée
en 1974 l'association regards parole
s'attelle à présenter une demi douzaine
d'expositions par an dans cet espace au
coeur de houdan faut savoir que depuis
12 ans nous sommes entièrement hébergée
par l'abbé par la mairie ce qu'il y a un
énorme cadeau donc pour remercier le
maire de cette action nous avons décidé
d'une façon commune enfin tous ensemble
de d'offrir à la commune une oeuvre
chacun d'entre nous offrir à une oeuvre
un grand projet de remerciements prévue
au mois de décembre pour les 28 artistes
du collectif dont l'exposition
actuellement en place et la dernière de
la saison
à présent bixente on embarque à bougival
1h30 de croisère supplément découvertes
le 5 juin prochain au départ de la halte
fluviale de bougival la croisière des
impressionnistes vous emmènera
tranquillement paisiblement dans
l'univers des peintres qui ont puisé
leur inspiration des bords de seine zivi
noah renoir monet sisley pour en parler
avec nous laurence françois responsable
du bureau d'information touristique de
bougival bonjour bonjour donc tout
d'abord cette croisière c'est une heure
et demie de balade fluviale est le
postulat c'est qu'au bout de sept heures
et demie on saura tout des
impressionnistes du bord de seine c'est
ça le problème le trajet qu'elle est le
trajet de ce fait donc on partira de
bougival bien sûr en passant par croatie
par l'agglo la grenouillère
leroyer malmaison château avec la maison
fournaise carrière sur scène et on
reviendra je pense au niveau nanterre
voilà le trajet cette thématique est
souvent déclinées en promenade par
exemple au bord de la seine autour des
impressionnistes quel est votre objectif
avec cette croisière c'est un format
plutôt détente
oui tout à fait c'est vraiment une
balade bucolique à une heure et piste
assez court mais on a le temps de
s'imprégner en fait des paysages des
passes et des paysages comparé
effectivement renoir monet
berthe morisot fils voulait donc en fait
on est vraiment au plus près de ses
paysages au coût de près du lot et
voilà donc ces c'est vraiment très
sympathique en général les personnes
sont toujours vraiment enchanté qu'il
fasse beaucoup moins beau mais en fait
on capte vraiment la lumière et reflets
changeants c'est on est dans un musée à
ciel ouvert
animations cet événement laurence
françois est le fruit d'une
collaboration entre bureau d'information
touristique de bougival y aussi avec
l'office de tourisme de versailles vous
êtes amené à de plus en plus collaborer
ensemble à l'avenir oui voilà donc on
devient et non une antenne de l'office
de tourisme de versailles voilà et donc
on va travailler sur le territoire de
versailles on parle donc nous ce qu'on
amène à vous avez effectivement c'est la
scène a donc c'est un gros point et les
impressionnistes si on est vraiment dans
le berceau des impressionnistes à
bougival on a eu tous les artistes
majeurs comme monet renoir bercon réseau
sisley pissarro
ils sont venus et qui ont par moody ban
on a recensé 150 de poils de ces
artistes sur vous dit ban voilà donc en
fait on est vraiment imprégnés bars et
on est en sortie et puis on fait partie
du contrat de dessinateurs du contrat de
destination
impressionnisme
de france normandie et on fait aussi
partie de la 32ème route culturelle
européenne du conseil de l'europe
merci beaucoup françois petite dernière
question au niveau des infos pratiques
le tarif est fixé à 24 euros donc départ
a à me dire de retour très importante
que qu'est-ce qu'il faut prévoir des
pique niques je crois
ballet pitt ni oui là c'est en effet ce
sera très bien ça va passer et ça passe
le temps c'est toujours bien bien
plaisant donc effectivement 24 euros
pour le biais de 13
pour les plus de 13 ans de 6 à 12 ans et
12 euros et les moins de 6 ans le billet
gratuit
si beaucoup toutes les informations de
toutes manières sont sur le site
versailles tourisme.com merci beaucoup
laurence françois responsable du bureau
d'information touristique de bougival
d'oaxaca avec nous merci à notre
deuxième invité à présent bixente comme
chaque semaine c'est vos agendas sont
vos agendas pour le week-end à venir
mais aussi ceux qui vont suivre avec
tout d'abord un salon du livre qui fait
son retour oui le 14e salon lisez local
de la librairie le pavé du canal à
montigny-le-bretonneux c'est ce samedi 4
juin de 15h à 18h30 le but c'est de
rencontrer dix auteurs locaux passionnés
de lecture et d'écriture et qui se sont
lancés pour écrire leur propre livre
c'est l'occasion idéale de découvrir
voilà des auteurs que vous ne connaissez
pas forcément de découvrir leur univers
où tout simplement de discuter
littérature on file à la semaine
prochaine bixente de rendez vous dont le
premier attendu depuis longtemps dans le
sud yves l'ennemi vendredi 10 juin
marquera le début du spectacle secret
défense à rambouillet un spectacle
immersif de grande ampleur dans
l'enceinte du château le bloc twist nous
sommes le 3 set en 1959 et vous venez
d'entrer au service de la france en
qualité d'agent de renseignements ce qui
va se passer au château de rambouillet
dans les heures qui viennent est
hautement stratégique tout ce dont vous
serez témoin est d'ores et déjà classé
secret défense en somme grégory les
services secrets vous participerez à des
réunions stratégiques que vous infiltrer
voilà tout ce qui est service secret
tout en prenant part à la soirée des
ambassadeurs pour participer il faut
bien entendu réservé sur le site secret
défense point fr
le spectacle est ouvert le vendredi de
18h30 à minuit les samedi et dimanche
toute la journée jusqu'à tard le soir il
me semble c'est 22 heures le dimanche et
minuit le samedi et donc jusqu'au
dimanche 3 juillet et enfin on prend la
direction d'un marché à présent et ce
n'est pas de fruits et légumes dont il
est question c'est à saint rémy les
chevreuse c'est ça grégory les dix a
enjoint saremi accueil sont attendus
marché de la céramique 30 céramiste ont
été retenus ils viennent de quatre
régions de france et exposeront place du
square de l'église une sortie pour venir
voir de nombreux travaux artistiques et
acheter vos coups de coeur pour
découvrir ce qui vous attend le marché
des potiers fait des petits trailer de
la sur son compte facebook je vous
invite à regarder ça c'est sympa sur les
différents céramiste qui seront présents
durant ces deux journées voilà pour
cette séquence agendas et on va clôturer
cette émission c'était un peu notre
petit coutume cette année bixente avec
de la musique par confiance et le début
des festivals d'été oui de nombreux
événements sont à prévoir dans vos
agendas durant tout le mois musiques du
monde jazz folk rock ou encore pop il y
en aura pour tous les goûts nous vous
avons préparé un top 5 des festivals à
ne pas manquer
[Musique]
allez
tubman
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qui donc si j'écris
m'entendrez par montagnat chine
merci bixente pour toutes ces idées de
sorties c'est un plaisir d'être avec
vous chaque vendredi à vos côtés pour
informer les yvelinois et leur donner
l'envié de sortir dans le département
j'espère que le plaisir était partagé
oui grégory j'espère que j'ai rempli ma
mission du mieux que possible et que
voilà j'ai j'ai bien renseigné bien
apporter tout ce dont les i mean noah
avait besoin pour l'heure où ils
voulaient parfaitement relevé bixente
alors vous inquiétez pas le sais tu ce
week-end est certes terminé dans sa
version actuelle mais les programmes
vont continuer sur tv 78 tout au long du
mois de juin avec des reportages des
idées de sorties toujours on en aura
besoin en ce mois de juin mais aussi des
émissions spéciales passer un excellent
week end et à très vite sur tv 78
[Musique]